بدأ رجلان تداول البيتكوين في نفس اليوم تماماً.
أحدهما قضى 12 ساعة أمام الشاشات،
يطارد كل شمعة خضراء بجنون.
لكن ليلة أمس، فخ واحد من "الحيتان"
بخر مدخرات حياته بالكامل في لحظات.
أما الرجل الآخر؟ لقد استمتع بعشائه مع عائلته،
ونام بعمق، ثم استيقظ على ربح 5,000 دولار.
الفرق لم يكن حظاً، بل كان في النظام المستخدم.
أحدهما كان "فريسة"، والآخر أصبح "ذكياً".
يفشل معظم المتداولين لأنهم يلعبون لعبة الحيتان.
يتم جرهم للشراء عندما يريد الكبار ذلك،
لكن عندما ينصب الحوت فخه، تكون أنت الضحية.
Trap Defence BTC يغير قواعد اللعبة
عبر كشف ما لا تراه العين في السوق.
محركنا يرصد تلاعب المؤسسات المالية الكبرى
قبل أن تضرب محفظتك وتدمر أرباحك.
نحن نمنحك السلاح الأقوى: الانضباط
لحماية أموالك حتى تصبح الاحتمالات في صالحك.
هذا هو نظام الدفاع عالي الدقة
للنجاة في سوق مليء بالمخاطر.
واليوم، يمكنك الحصول على هذا السلاح مجاناً.
انضم إلى Academy الآن واحصل على
Trap Score مجاناً وبدون أي تكلفة.
لا حاجة لبطاقة ائتمان، ولا مبالغات زائفة.
هناك فقط حقيقة السوق العارية أمامك.
توقف عن كونك فريسة، كن أنت من يسيطر.
انقر أدناه لتفعيل "البوت"
واستلم صلاحية الوصول المجاني الآن.
ابدأ الآن.
الدخول من هنا.